mais oui j'ai déjà essayé et j'ai essayé
peut-être cinq ou six fois dame depuis
vous êtes élus et leurs noms dans la vie
au complet de les raconter j'étais dans
un un souper entre amis chez moi sur la
terrasse en arrière de la maison il ya
quelqu'un qui avait un joint il l'a
allumé on l'a passé j'ai ptet j'ai pris
une baffe et j'ai et je les passais à la
prochaine personne c'est pas quelque
chose qui est du du de l'inconnu pour la
grande majorité des canadiens est ce que
pour vous ce tuner non c'est pas une
erreur je ne consomme pas du cannabis je
suis pas un grand consommateur du tout
j'ai déjà essayé et je trouve que c'est
un exemple où la population et les
citoyens sont complètement ailleurs que
la masse politique surtout que ce
gouvernement si qui continuent
d'attaquer et d'être agressif là dessus
une des raisons pour laquelle je suis
krul l'égalisation c'est que justement
ça va nous permettre d'éliminer beaucoup
plus l'accès aux jeunes à la marine one
même ceux qui sont en désaccord avec moi
mon respecter le fait que je me base sur
la science je respecte le choix et la
liberté de choix des autres et je suis
ouvert et et intègre dans la façon que
je me représente